if you google best lomo scene ever
you'll find the matrix
lobby scene over and over again it is
actually a 3 minute 13 second
tapestry of 74 apparently normal clips
and just 35 slow motion ones yet this
is what we remember
[Music]
slow motion animates sports and sells
iphones
and is so powerful in movies it can make
you forget
everything else in the scene how does it
work
[Music]
to demonstrate the principles of slow
motion we actually hired a world-class
juggler
to show how a lot of the fundamental
ideas still
okay it throws me off when you pan up to
my face
it's not supposed to be in the shot so
though this juggling is filmed with a
digital camera the fundamental
principles
are the same as they were with film this
one second clip is shot and played
at about 24 frames a second 24 pictures
today's standard speed for movies now
let's say we film this
at 60 pictures a second
if we play back both clips at a rate of
24 frames a second
the 60 pictures take two and a half
times longer to play
than just 24 pictures that is slow
motion
this comes with some technical hurdles
especially when it comes to lighting
imagine a door opening and closing the
let light in
if i take 24 pictures a second the
camera door the shutter
will be open for about 1 50th of a
second
to let in the right amount of light and
a nice amount of blur
in the motion not enough blur
and things look disorientingly sharp
too much and they look fuzzy 1 50th is
just right for what we think of
as a cinematic look if i take 60
pictures a second
see how everything is darker that's
because i need to use a higher shutter
speed when i'm shooting more frames per
second
the door is slamming open and shut more
quickly
there's less time for light to hit the
camera sensor
or the film to lighten it i have to
crank the light
or use more sensitive film or in a
digital camera use a higher iso setting
once this is all done you can control
not just how your picture looks
but how it moves because these rules
are so important to capturing any image
the potential to shape motion was
obvious
from the beginning of photography and
just like the slo-mo tennis balls
early pioneers took lots of pictures
quickly to slow down time
a process that transitioned to actually
filming motion
see this crank early film was often
though not always
fed through the camera manually to
control the speed of a picture cameraman
used this to their cinematic advantage
they often overcranked cranked too fast
to put more film frames in front of the
camera in a shorter period of time
that would record slower motion or they
undercranked
cranked too slow to make things look
faster
movie projectors could be messed with
too this 1897 film
charity ball looks dreamy and slow-mo
when played at say
22 frames a second but realistic when
played
at 40 frames a second setting rules for
movies required the one thing that was
missing
sound if i bounce this ball on a tennis
racket the speed of the audio and video
have to be the same
otherwise it falls out of sync this idea
became
increasingly important in the late 1920s
when films with sound
called talkies became the norm
they didn't work if film recording and
playback speeds were all over the place
which they were in 1927 the society of
motion picture
engineers noted that the sound recording
device
must be perfectly synchronized with the
camera the jazz singer
the first hockey a 1927 movie that
centered on a blackface performer
was made thanks to a company called
vitaphone their technology synced
recording speed using
a mechanical engine not a person at a
crank
the motion picture engineers followed
vitaphone standard
and settled on 24 frames a second
confusion about playback and film speed
was over
with a standard established people were
free to experiment
slow motion had already been used in
science and sports
like newsreel footage of baseball player
babe ruth
foreign filmmaker and nazi propagandist
lenny riefenstahl's
olympics documentary
[Applause]
[Music]
beyond sports there was some slow-mo
dabbling in hollywood
like the dreamlike hunting party
photography in this
1932 musical
in 1938 fred astaire and ginger rogers
danced in slow-mo too
[Music]
but these slow motion scenes were rare
french filmmaker
and theorist john epstein played with
slomo in
the fall of the house of usher he wrote
slow motion really brings a new set of
possibilities to dramaturgy
its ability to dismantle feelings to
enhance drama
surpasses all the other known tragic
modes
1930s french film zero for conduct
featured a slow motion scene after a
pillow fight
and it's like a wes anderson epilogue
john cocteau's orpheus used slow motion
to add drama
to a dreamy sequence
and akira kurosawa whose groundbreaking
hint 7 samurai featured slo-mo
helped influence hollywood to add
slow-mo to action
and narrative no longer just for sports
musicals or
outsider artistes slow motion appeared
at more than 100 frames per second in
the final shooting
in 1967's bonnie and clyde
by the 80s it was suitable for
everything from blood rushing from an
elevator
[Music]
to the end of a glorious race
[Music]
slow motion was an established trope by
the 1990s one with
rules and references and expectations
even today some tech obstacles exist
film with your iphone in regular motion
and slow motion notice that noise that's
the phone compensating for less light
by making the sensor more sensitive
raising the iso
but for movies with speeds at thousands
of frames a second possible
in vfx augmentation common slow motion
has fully become
an aesthetic storytelling tool rather
than a technological hurdle
it was obvious from the beginning of
photography but now slow motion has
developed a full range of meanings
and uses it can make three minutes and
13 seconds
iconic a lobby run becomes a study in
momentum
a bus stop becomes a reunion
reckless driving becomes flight and bad
juggling
becomes a story of time and light
[Music]
so while i was wrapping up this slow
motion video i got to wear these recon
ear buds at my computer
and they are the sponsor of this video
do you know how long it takes to pick
music recon earbuds last for six hours
of playtime
and i can use it
[Music]
it's got the detail i need they sound
just as good as other premium earbuds
recon gave me this pair but the price
actually starts at
half of other buds and that's a good
thing because i work at home
so i can listen all day without
disturbing the
napping baby over there
are you asleep see
these everyday e25 earbuds are the best
yet it's bluetooth
it's bassy and the fit is great and it's
pretty discreet
too which is good since no one will know
what kind of music i'm listening to when
i'm doing
fake slow motion around the house
so click that link and check out buy
recon dot com
slash vox you'll get 15 off
you'll have new earbuds that look and
sound great whether you're trying to
finish
a video or listen to a podcast while
you're juggling
raycon doesn't directly impact our
editorial but their support
helps make videos like this possible
you